Marina: Hello! My name is Marina. I will be doing a self-guided task. titled S.
Marina: GT. Tracking your expenses with money manager 2
Marina: UOCI dash RCL. Dash 9. So I'm going to be going through a lot of stuff today. This is on Android with Talkback.
Marina: And
Marina: so to start. So I believe the first thing I need to do
Marina: is create sort of X-rays categories
Marina: and Pradesh.
Marina: Well, I'm on the home page. More options. But category. Name
Marina: your expenses this month. Total expenses bad expense, button, button.
Marina: double tap to activate.
Marina: So I'm on the home screen, which is like, I guess where it shows the expenses.
Marina:  and I guess from the get-go annotation. But at total you're academic more a month, 6 covin navigation drawer, button.
Marina: double tap to activate.
Marina: So just puts you on the screen and you first launch the app for the first time. It doesn't do any onboarding stuff
Marina: here, so you can kind of get started.
Marina: which I feel like that would be beneficial, because otherwise it would be difficult to figure out.
Marina: You know, how do I add these categories.
Marina: So in this case, then, I'm going to have to figure this out on my own with that and onboarding guide.
Marina: Anyway, month's expenses.
Marina: more options, button, double tap to activate, double, tap, and hold to long press.
Marina: Start by maybe doing, you know, puts on on that more actions or more. More more options.
Marina: Pop up window your wallet, enlist, add income settings. annotation, button out of list, window settings, enlist window hub of window.
Marina: double tap, tap.
Marina: money manager, more options, monthly open navigation money manager checked month's expenses, budget categories, budget analysis. monthly expenses, analysis, budget plans, annotation. But but monthly budget is budget categories.
Marina: double tap to activate.
Marina: So rather than it being called expense categories, it looks like it's called budget categories. so that can be bit
Marina: confusing.
Marina: But anyway.
Marina: so like, I said in the notes that I'm looking at that looks like there's a lot of stuff. So I think what I should do first is back out of this menu
Marina: nova 7
Marina: zoom out of grid, right? So what I did was I pressed the back button.
Marina: or I did the back gesture with top back and rounded, unclosed a menu. It took me back to my home screen
Marina: apologies for the pause. I had to
Marina: get back into the app. So now that I'm not able to close the menu.
Marina: I have to select something. So
Marina: bunch budget categories checked money, checked month's expenses. So let's just click back into month's expenses. Open navigation drawer, come on, 6 more options, button, and then from there hit the more actions or more options.
Marina: Pop up, window, your wallet in lit at an income double tap to activate. And I'm gonna have add in.
Marina: I'm gonna go to your income.
Marina: add to your wallet, add income button out of list money amount, edit box.
Marina: and if that to your wallet. add income, button. double tap to activate
Marina: battery, 68% windows. The add income button.
Marina: double. Tap that to your wallet.
Marina: adding money, amount edit box.
Marina: show me number T board.
Marina: So for this test I'm just going to put in
Marina: for the income. A $1,000, 4, with one.
Marina: 1, 8 period.
Marina: share audio, stop, share, button, 8. Look, share audio on button, great double tap, tap. So, thanks to zoom overlay, we, it's blocking a 0. So I'm gonna have to swipe over a couple of times. Annotate swiped back.
Marina: Done period 0
Marina: 0 0 0.
Marina: So we're putting it down. Large
Marina: bad income editing, 1,000 edit box, clear text one. When it add to your wallet bad income, button.
Marina: double tap to activate. And rather than that thing saying, add income, I feel like that should be labeled as save
Marina: just my thinking. So I'm gonna double tap. This hopefully it saves the information your wallet contains. Now 1,000 point. Oh, keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigation drawer, button, double tap to activate.
Marina: It's great. That talkback said. You know your wallet now contains whatever amount.
Marina: However, it didn't even say, you know $1,000. So
Marina: it's like 1,000. What exactly to.
Marina: I'm not sure if this is something that's dealt with in the settings app, but it's anyway
Marina: months, expensive. More options, button category. Make your expenses this month. Total expenses add expense, button, button annotation button, add expense, button button window. So let's say, you know, totally new. With this.
Marina: you know, I'm new to these app to zap. So what I'm gonna do
Marina: is act like, I want to add something here to the expenses.
Marina: even though I have no categories add new transaction product, category. drop-down list.
Marina: double tap to change labels available used. And let's see what happens when I click on this dropdown.
Marina: And because I don't have anything. Well, here's what I was expecting to happen. Let me strike to the right one more time. See what happens.
Marina: Enter info edit box characters entered 0 10.
Marina: Enter info edit. Box. Transaction date. 2,024, Tuesday, February previous month, button next previous Tuesday. 2,000 transactions. Answer. Info edit. Box
Marina: characters entered 0. Enter in drop-down list, enter info edit, box. double tap to edit text, double tap, and hold to long press.
Marina: So rather than telling me what these edit boxes are for. It just says
Marina: you know how many characters are remaining, so I don't know what I'm supposed to enter in each edit box. It just tells me the character limit.
Marina: Care entering transaction 2,022, 3 next month. Button double tap to activate.
Marina: Now I've got talkback. Tell me there's some sort of calendar sitting here.
The sixth of February the seventh, the fifteenth of the 20 ninth of February.
Marina: Annotation button window annotate. Enter info edit box with add new transaction
Marina: characters entered. Enter Info drop, add nutrients.
Marina: county category. Great.
Marina: I've got a feeling. If I try to back out. It's going to probably take me back to my home screen again. Since I can't really add anything. Put up the background of the screen
Marina: drop-down list. Chronic. Add new transaction. Hmm. The seventeenth of February, the 20 fourth of February 2024, and transaction date. Enter info edit. Button.
Marina: the the fourteenth of February 2024, Tuesday. Everywhere
Marina: enter info character, enter in transaction 2,024, Tuesday, February 27, 2,024,
Marina: 2, 3 days, month next month. Button. So if I try to back down using the talkback command to back.
Marina: go back for even
selected today the 20 seventh of February twentieth. Oh, no, I don't have that. Never mind. So I'm just gonna use the talk back
Marina: gesture to go back.
Marina: And it. That doesn't work. Tuesday, February 20, manager that expense button, or it just made a wire out of me. I think I found the end back. Back out of that window.
Marina: and that I've said it looks like I have to add
Marina: so to myself here, Category, Nico.
Marina: So to do that I think I have to bring up the left menu
Marina: open navigation drawer button. So we're talking about this button that's highlighting
Marina: on the left-hand side. Money manager. Manage your budget. Check checked month's expensive budget categories. double tap to have open navigation, drawer, button.
Marina: budget, categories, more options, but category. Name budget
Marina: unlabeled button annotation, button unlabeled. It category name
Marina: great so
Marina: this is a
Marina: so I'm not sure whatever I'm supposed to do that's part of
Marina: if that's going to be part of the categories. When I start adding transactions.
Marina: Budget unlabeled button
Marina: double tap to activate labels available. Use tap with 3 fingers to view
Marina: budget category info category, name edit boffs.
Marina: double tap to edit test double tap and hold a long breath
Marina: shown English us QWER, TY.
Marina: So for this one I'm going to add a couple of them. So we can see how this flow works.
Marina: So for the first one we're going to put in housing.
Marina: G. Bill, HSC. Annotation H. Go to H.
Marina: Hi, India. Oh, UES.
Marina: I, Nope, NF. Pops, GG. Possibly budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Right? The maximum. Add income, button, open features, menu, open open features next open features. Menu. Alright. So. Editing, housing, edit box. I thought it was a
Marina: expenses category, but it looks like it's not
Marina: not exactly sure on characters entered 7 to 50.
Marina: There's got to be something else.
Marina: Budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Edit box. double tap to edit. Test. right? The maximum amount of money you can spend in this category.
Marina: Hmm!
Marina: Looking over my notes again. By the way.
Marina: yeah. So I don't know how I'm supposed to add an expenses category when I'm not finding and expenses category.
Marina: So I'm gonna back out of this screen, possibly for yeah. Back out of this.
Marina: keep working
Marina: bad income button. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Hmm, okay. So budget characters, how's the budget category? Stop share. But and it's bad and write the maximum amount
Marina: money manager, open navigation drawer, button budget, cap, more options, button. double tap to activate budget open navigation drawer button. There's gonna have to have to be. There's gotta be something else here.
Marina: Money manager month, 6, check budget, category budget analysis, monthly expenses, analysis. budget plans, annotation, but monthly budget of checked month's expenses.
Marina: double tap, tap, open navigation drawer button. Come on 6 more option pop-up window. Your wallet in add income settings annotation. Set that in settings
Marina: alright. So looks like I'm gonna be going through all these different screens to find expenses categories, because I'm not finding where what I'm looking for in any of these areas that I just went through. So I'm just gonna go through every part of the app, I guess.
Marina: Bad income
Marina: settings, adding your wallet, your wallet, $1,000 close button annotation. Clip one to your wallet.
Marina: What close
Marina: money, manager, more options, category, more options. Button, pop up window. Your ad income settings
Marina: double tap to activate that in your wallet
Marina: double tap to activate, and it's setting money manager more option category, your expenses this month.
Marina: Category. Name
Marina: your extent, total expense that extent, annotation, but share
Marina: more options. We don't pop up window your wallet and settings
Marina: money manager, more options, category name, more optics, open navigation drawer, button.
Marina: double tap to activate.
Marina: So what I'm gonna do, since I'm not finding what I'm looking for, I'm gonna
Marina: go to the screen where I can add mixpence. And then I'm gonna have to
Marina: do something else.
So more, I'll kind of because you're it's a totally sad expense. Budget.
Marina: Yeah, new transaction chronic cat.
Marina: Alright.
Marina: So from here I'm just gonna have to
Marina: ask something real quick. So pause.
Marina: Great apologies for this paused app has been
Marina: confusing. I and I need some clarification.
Marina: Wonder how to proceed.
Marina: So we are now on the menu. I believe.
Marina: monthly expenses, analysis budget plans, budget checked month budget categories. double tap to activate. And it looks like, I have to go to budget categories.
Marina: open navigation drawer, button
Marina: budget categories, more options. But category. Name budget unlabeled button
Marina: double tap to activate labels. Available. Use tab with 3 fingers to view.
Marina: and it looks like we have an unlabeled button. I don't know if I mentioned that earlier, so I'm gonna use this to add a category budget category info category. Name, edit.
Marina: Double tap to edit text, double tap. shit
Marina: capital HOOU. ED. Delta SS.
Marina: Jay, Juliet I.
Marina: B. Bravo, NNGG. G.
Marina: Bad income button. When to write the maximum budget, write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category Eddybox. double tap, the back
Marina: button showing number keyboard.
Marina: And then for this, since I want to write a maximum amount.
Marina: Since we're thinking of something that can fluctuate over time, you know, because it's gonna include utilities and whatnot. I'm just gonna put in
Marina: like, I don't know. 8 50, I guess. 5, 6, 9, 9, one. Delete comma 0 0 0
editing, 9. Clear text. Write the maximum on the ad income, button
Marina: double tap to active one. 1, 1 1. Write the map clear F, care housing at Budget Head.
Marina: health care. We write them as them add in one window number, add income button window budget category info.
Marina: So I'm not sure why this is happening. But that button where does add income? It shouldn't even be saying that because it's not the income screen. This is a budget category screen. So not label correctly.
Marina: And the
Marina: I think that's it for that issue, I'm gonna double tap. Oh, no. The other issue is that instead of it being called, add income, I believe it should be called. It should just be a save button
Marina:  And then, in regards to placements, I feel like that should be like on the upper right.
Marina: like there should be a save on the upper right, and then, if you don't want to add it, there should be a cancel button which should be on the upper left.
Marina: So I'm gonna save it now. I'm gonna double tap
Marina: keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigation drawer, button, double tap to activate. We're gonna see if it shows up to talk back.
Marina: you know, but talkback notices anything
Marina: with this. You know, if it notices that I've added a new scene. or if it's going to treat it as an unlabeled item. Budget morocco category budget housing. Enlist $900
Marina: unlabeled button annotation, button window unlabeled button window money manager. And again the add button is not labeled.
Marina: and I feel like for that. That should be like on the upper right. More better, more options, button window money. Oh, no, that's not gonna work, because we have more options. So
Marina: guess forget that.
Marina: But any rate, like I, said, the button to add, another category is unlabeled.
Marina: This is how it is. Let's how it was at the beginning as well.
Marina: $900 in list. double unlabeled button out of. I see where it's at, but that I guess that'll work, too. to have it on the bottom. Right? The budget category info category. Name edit boss.
Marina: Double tap to edit test.
Marina: Yeah. Showing English. Put in about
Marina: her.
Marina: Let's do shit with capital S.
Marina: Capital. S. I'm just gonna put in shopping HPO. Off PO OS per PPI eva GG
Marina: right.
Marina: and then
Marina: so there, I'm gonna do H. Excuse me better for the next thing.
Marina: Budget, write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category, and it bobs window budget, category info carrots budget right to that
Marina: button showing number keyboard. So for that one, I'm just gonna say
Marina: 200, maybe 3,
Marina: 2, 2 period 8. Yeah. So 0 is being blocked by the 00, no, it's not 0 period.
Marina: Stop share 0 0.
Marina: I'm surprised. I was able to put that in. I was having the issues earlier.
editing 200 edit, clear text, right? The maximum, add income button.
Marina: And again
Marina: it says, add income rather than save or add expense, or whatever.
Marina: or save category. I'm just gonna double tap
Marina: keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigation drawer, button, double tap to activate
Marina: and then
Marina: for food. No, I'm gonna do another one here. Unlabeled. Button
Marina: the budget category, yeah. Double tap to edit test. Excuse me. So I'm gonna add one file category, which will be
Marina: label food characters and budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Care category, name, edit.
Marina: shift with capital. G.
Marina: Capital d. Delta. Capital FPOI. India, OOD. Delta, d
Marina: bad income, button, open features, menu budget, category. editing food characters and budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category edit box. Quebec button showing number keyboard.
Marina: Alright. So I'm gonna for this one. I'm also gonna put in
Marina: 200, maybe free.
Marina: Add income, 2, 2,
Marina: okay.
Marina: 0, 0 period.
Marina: 8, 5, 8 0 0,
Marina: add income, button, wait.
Marina: keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigate. So now we have 3 categories. And I'm gonna go to the
Marina: monthly expenses, category and money manager, man month month's expenses. month's expenses. I'm gonna double tap on that open navigation drawer button. double tap to activate.
Marina: Now that I'm on that, let's see if I can now add something else. Expect more option. Category. Name your expenses this month. Housing 0%, $0, 900% slider.
Marina: swipe up or swipe down to adjust labels available use tap with 3 fingers to view.
Marina: So for this
Marina: we have ourselves here. Talkback is categorizing this as a Slider
Marina: route around like some sort of either some sort of custom. Singh
Marina: or Progress bar, or something. to give us an idea. And because it's categorizing this as a slider.
Marina: technically speaking, or, theoretically speaking, I can adjust this Slider.
Marina: 5%, 10%, 15% like so and I haven't even added anything. And I can adjust the Slider.
Marina: And that's not supposed to happen. So let's set it back
Marina: by 0%.
Marina: And let's now start adding stuff.
Marina: $0, night shopping, 0%, $0, 200 food, 0% slight $0, $200.
Marina: Alright. So looks like I have a
Marina: I do like how this is coming along. I'm gonna
Marina: hopefully find some stuff here. Total expense. Add expense, button button.
Marina: There it is, I see, an add expense button. I do like that. This button is labeled as such.
Marina: I'm going to double tap on it. Add new transaction product, category.
drop-down list, housing
Marina: double. Enter info edit box.
The characters entered 0 10.
Marina: So like before. It's a
Marina: doesn't tell me what to what I can write in. It just says characters entered 0 a 10, so that tells me nothing.
Marina: Enter info edit boss. double tap to edit test. Here. Enter info edit box. So for both edit boxes. All it just says is, enter info. So that tells me. Yeah.
Marina: Doesn't tell me much. However, what I am concerned about right now is the product category drop-down list housing.
Marina: double tap to change? Oh, yeah, that's right. So it already selected housing for me. But I'm gonna see if this works. Anyway, I'm gonna double tap on this product category dropdown
Marina: pop-up window housing, enlist, shopping, food.
Marina: annotation, food, shopping, housing.
Marina: double tap. Just
Marina: add new transaction, drop-down list, housing. Enter info, edit box.
Marina: double tap to edit, test, double tap and hold to long press.
Marina: Can I double tap shown English? USQW. VRTY. Okay. So
Marina: I was gonna try, you know. Figure this out on my own.
Marina: and we're gonna see what you know if
Marina: it brings it the same keyboard on the next edit box characters and enter info edit box. Knock the back button showing number T board. Hmm.
Marina: okay, so let's just do this.
Marina: put in 600. Then for the amount cause it looks like this is an amount box. It says, Talk back. Decided not to tell me that I could. And you know that it's asking for an amount.
Marina: So basically like the edit boxes are not labeled correctly.
Marina: I'm just gonna put in here. Space
Marina: 6, 6, 8, 0
Marina: 0 0 600
Marina: editing, 600. Yep. dollar sign. clear text, but transaction date.
Marina: clear technology, editing characters, and enter info edit, box.
Marina: double tap to edit text, double tap and hold to long press annotation shift
Marina: capital r rope, EDB. Bravo, NTT. Okay.
Marina: Editing random
Marina: cleartech characters entered 4, 10, $600, not transaction.
Marina: Tuesday, February 27
Marina: double tap to have to be. Now I've got a calendar here. Hello, Wallace! Bee! Bravo! Space! The bell! The week's next release. That's what talk back was highlighting.
Marina: But what we have below right now is this keyboard? So I'm gonna try to dismiss that
Marina: showing number keyboard done double tapping
600 edit box entered Info.
Marina: the thirteenth of February the fourth of February 2024, the eighth of February, the first of February 2024
Marina: double tap. So let's double. Tap this to see if it gets selected. Thursday, February first, 2024. Selected
Marina: excellent
Marina: speech. Read 161% speech. Read one, pardon me.
selected the first of February 2024,
Marina: so it does say that selected which is good.
Marina: Now let's try to save it.
Marina: Add transaction button out of Gager, and I was able to find it by doing my one finger. Drag it said, add transaction.
Marina: Barbara. I would have liked it to be labeled Safe Transaction or just save.
Marina: and possibly the other thing that would have been useful characters entered 4 10
Marina: would be to probably have it on the upper right.
Marina: you know, like a save button and and a cancel button on the upper left. So let's save the transaction.
Marina: and that transaction buttons
Marina: double tap to activate transaction. Budget category equals. One product name equals. Rent. Price equals 600.0 by date equals Thursday, February first, 10, a oh, 2 Pacific standard time, 2024
Marina: money manager, open navigation. So I don't know if you heard what it just said. But basically it almost sounds like technical jargon cause it said, budget category equals one
Marina: when
Marina: and then it said, all this other stuff equals this and that. I think what would have been best. What would have been
Marina: butter would have been to have it say something like
Marina:  you know, expense saved something like that.
Marina: So let's see if anything got effective here in regards to any sliders or whatever.
Marina: Alright, so looks like I'm almost out of time. And so
Marina: that's gonna be there's still a lot to do according to this task.
Marina:  But what I want to do is see the Slider here, how that all works. If anything gets affected here, Shelby.
Marina: 60 s housing. You're expecting housing 67% Slider
Marina: swipe up or swipe down to adjust labels available. Use tab with 3 fingers to view. So it does say, you know, this Slider does change according to what you added. However, again, I'm going to emphasize that, for whatever reason you can change the slider
Marina:  you can change the slider around, because, you know, Talkback says it the Slider. So you can actually fumble around with it. 62, 56, 62%,
Marina: 72%, 67%. Yeah. So I wanna
Marina: look over my notes because some
Marina: feel like there's more to this.
Marina: Alright. So next I need to see how renaming a budget works.
Marina: Category, name, open navigation drawer, button there, double tap to activate. Bring up this menu here. money manager, check month, budget, budget categories.
Marina: check covid navigation drawer, button
Marina: and tap to have to be. And I'm gonna look over this
$200,
Marina: double tattoo $100, food.
Marina: $200, food, 200 unlabeled bunnett, 2 food, double tap to activate. Excuse me. So I'm going to tap double tap on the food one. See if I can do anything with it. Budget, category, info food, edit, box characters entered 450
Marina: food bedbox category name food. You cannot change the category name shown English us. QW. VR, okay, I don't know why it just did that when I double tipped that text box. It basically flagged an error so that I can't change that category name. But then it also brought up the keyboard, anyway.
Marina: So let's see if I can actually change it, regardless of what it just told me. Billy's next delete
Marina: no, I can't. I don't think spell check.
Marina: speech, rate link headings, paragraphs, words, characters, ETT, yeah. Open features, menu. Show food, open features, menu.
Marina: double tap to activate editing food. Edit box, category, name.
Marina: capital. F,
Marina: oh, oh, d and a field delete d de deleted! Oh, delete O delete f deleted so. What I was expecting to happen was when I double tapped on the text. Field, assuming it didn't flag an error like it did.
Marina: I was expecting it to put the cursor at the end of the word.
Marina: So let's just put it now. Recreation.
Marina: more symbols.
Marina: annotation, but more simple, faster is more simple. F, 2.
Marina: Letter keyboard with your simple keyboard.
Marina: double tap, open features. Menu, TG ship capital. R,
Marina: E,
Marina: see C,
Marina: so we're just gonna shorthand. And just say, you know our Ec for recreation.
Marina: E red.
Marina: we we yeah, 200 point. Oh, clear test, right? The maximum amount of butt. Let's see what happens. Clear characters, and please add in open features, menu next
Marina: double tap to have to go
Marina: adding, button window budget. Here it is. I'm gonna hit. That save button. It's supposed to be a save button
Marina: keyboard hidden money manager, open navigation, draw budget, hack more category budget housing 9 months shall pay 200 red
Marina: $200. Alright. So it actually did change the name for me.
Marina: So I don't know why that error came up the way it did. Why, I said, you can't change the name. I mean. I.
Marina: Our train was able to.
Marina: Now.
Marina: I'm supposed to create a
Marina: budget plan housing, category, name, open navigation drawer.
Marina: many money.
Marina: monthly expense of budget plans. double tap to activate
Marina: open navigation drawer. But budget, plan more option. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. The deadline, the dead. The deadline of this plan has passed. The deadline of this plan has passed.
Marina: Hmm, unlabeled button.
Marina: Yeah, I don't know exactly what that all means. So what I'm just gonna do is the unlabeled button. We have ourselves another unabled button. double tap, plan, info plan, title, edit, box.
Marina: double-tap characters, entered. Plan, description, edit. Bops, characters entered 0 plans, budget, editbox
Marina: plan, deadline date. 2,024,
Marina: double tap to have Tuesday, February 20, seventh, 2,000 planned deck plans, characters, and clandest friction. What I would have liked to see on this is
Marina: like, you know. give us a.
Marina: It was like more details on what I'm supposed to do on this screen, or what's the purpose of
Marina: having a budget plan? What's that supposed to do?
Marina:  So what I'm gonna do just charging stops battery level 80%, just because we're almost out of time, or whatever I'm just gonna hook up my external keyboard
Marina: so I can start typing plan, info, plan, title, edit, boss.
Marina: double tap to edit text, double tap, and hold a longer. So for this, since I don't exactly know what this is for just gonna put in test T
Marina: characters into planned description. Bennett box
Marina: editing plan, description edit. Bob so didn't tell me that I was a editing
Marina: when I double tap. So I had to kind of verify that. So empty it's gonna put in test. editing test edit box characters entered for test edit, box characters, plans, budget edit box.
Marina: So when I used my external keyboard, what I was expecting to happen when I tabbed over, I was expecting to go to the next edit box dollar sign showing physical keyboard.
Marina: So with plans, budgets, let's say, I guess we're like
Marina: 500 or No. 404 0. Let's do 400.
Marina: Looks like everything's in correctly here. So
Marina: dollar sign, clear text plan, deadline date 2,024,
Marina: yeah. Tuesday, February 27.
Hey?
Marina: Alright! So let's do this for
Marina: the third, the fifth of February 2024, the 60'clock. This is the first next month, but in page 1491 of 2,000,
Marina: the seventh of March 2024, the first of March 2020, Friday, March first, 2024, selected. Friday, March first, editing 4, and a plan. Friday, March first. Double tap to have to be
Marina: the 20 sixth, the 30 of them march 2020. Alright. So I put everything in there and let's see what happens. I'm gonna look for like some sort of button to save it. Test edit. Bob's plan, info
Marina: character tech character editing for dollars. Not clear text button, double tap to activate this thing says I'm still editing in that
Marina: amount. So let's just see if I, pressing enter will get me out of that.
Marina: Friday, March first. Perfect press all plus enter to activate previous month, Friday, 2,000 point planned deadline dollar sign 400 edit. Great. So I did add everything in it that I needed to add
Marina: the 20 ninth of March 2024,
stop, share button
Marina: the twentieth, the thirtieth of march, switch input method, button out of key share audio.
Marina: the the tenth of month test test, edit, plan it.
Marina: stop, share share authentic switch in the back.
Marina: Beth.
Marina: but it's great
Marina: right back here. But no, I don't want to do that. The twentieth of March 2020, the 20 ninth of March 2024 annotation button the fourth of March.
Marina: Add plan, button out of cager, alright perfect. So scrolling up that actually reveals a button that native.
Marina: Let's double tap it. Your plan added successfully. Keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigation bunch of more options. Your wallet contains enough money for this.
Marina: Your wallet contains. The deadline, the deadline test test. Friday, March first, 2024 $400 in list. Unlabeled button out of lift. Annotation button. Untest test test. Friday, March first, 2024.
Marina: Alright. So let's see if
Marina: okay. So I need to create a
which I did there.
Marina: And now looks like I need to look at the analysis.
Marina: There are 2 analysis results I need to look at apparently. So let's
Marina: go. Bring up the menu. Your wallet, keep coping, navigation, drill.
Marina: monthly expense checked budget like annotation button check monthly expenses, analysis, budget analysis.
Marina: double tap to activate budget categories, budget analysis. So let's look at budget analysis and see what happens here.
Marina: Open navigation drawer budget and adds more with you. Pie chart, entitled Your Expenses per Category this month, with one points min. Value is 600. Max value is 600 article.
Marina: any charge, trial version link, any chart. Javascript charts designed to be embedded and integrated. V, 8.4 point 2 dot, one housing.
Marina: shopping, housing, 0 over 0
Marina: for more information.
Marina: Visit our website. Annotation button window annotation. So even though I didn't have enough time to add
Marina: more to the expenses. It's still well, what I noticed is, it's not exactly.
Marina: that useful! I would prefer to look over like the actual data within the month's expenses. Tab as opposed to a church.
Marina: Let's see about the budget plan one open navigation
Marina: and money manager
Marina: month's expenses. Budget check, but monthly expenses. Analysis checked budget analysis. Oh, so this was budget analysis. So yeah, that one's kind of interesting.
Marina: Let's look at that monthly expenses, another one monthly expenses, and see what happens here. Check open navigation drawer monthly, Morosh, with you.
Marina: Annotation button window, Webview window money manager. Excellent. So looks like I'm not able to
Marina: hold on so looks like I'm not able to look over this info. All that talkback does
Marina: is that it's a says web view, and then if I swipe again, then I'm just brought to my zoom overlay. So I'm not able to look over anything
Marina:  and besides, what I've noticed is with my personal experiences, with charts and whatnot. There hasn't been a
Marina: decent way to make 3. So sort of charts accessible. But anyway. yeah. So this for this one. So for the first one that I looked at, I was able to look at some stuff.
Marina: But then, for the one I'm currently on. I'm not able to read anything.
Marina: So, and I feel like, maybe for this one or for both charts to make it accessible. I just realized something. So
Marina: with artificial intelligence and all that, I feel like, what what can be done is  to make it accessible. Maybe you can run for. you know, using Chat Gptp, or whatever
Marina: model we want to do some good, maybe have that
Marina: describe a church. you know, assuming that you're using talkback.
Marina: and maybe that'd be the best way to make it usable.
Marina: We'd be to run it through some sort of AI engine
Marina: that can describe the chart for the user.
Marina: So
and summary
Marina: I was able to. What I was able to do was add expenses or no. I was it. I first had to add budget categories. which, if there was an onboarding
Marina: feature to begin with, so I would have been able to do that quickly before I'm trying to add expenses.
Marina: Then there was able to add
Marina: so from there I added categories, I encountered some unlabeled buttons and
Marina: buttons that were not labeled properly.
Marina: and then, after that are there to ask? Well, one expense.
Marina: I wasn't able to add more due to time constraints.
Marina: Then, after that I
Marina: then looked at trying to edit one of my budget categories. Whatever reason Talkback
Marina: stated that I couldn't change a name, but I actually was able to.
Marina: So that's kind of a strange one.
Marina: and then once I didn't edit that. Then I decided to look over 2 different charts.
Marina: One chart was somewhat usable while the one I'm currently on it. Talk back, then let me view it at all.
Marina: And my suggestion, even though first I was thinking there wasn't nothing that, you know, there wasn't anything that could be done. My suggestion overall would be, you know, to make it usable. Make both church usable, you know. Maybe haven't run, you know. Maybe somehow, integrate the use of AI,
Marina: you have some sort of AI model so that it can describe the charts to the user.
Marina: So money manager, open navigation drawer, that is. That is it for today. Thank you for watching and listening, and thank you for implementing accessibility into your product. Have a great day.